are you a sex and the city fan and where
does your loyalty lie
team big or team aiden
yes i'm a fan i was a fan before i met
john
um which one was i i was
there's an old running feud between our
families like the happiness and mccoy
something like that so let's of course
start things off by talking about
jl family ranch the wedding gift what
was it about this project that you were
like i gotta do it
i've known john boyd a long time i i
think he's just the most wonderful man
this is john boyd's baby this movie and
it was so much fun to watch him produce
and get the best out of everybody
in every department um and of course
he's a
brilliant actor so it was really fun and
my scenes are with him
so it was a real treat i like to call it
like the trifecta
of iconic actors you've got bo derek
you've got james khan and you've got
john voight so
like you previously said most of your
scenes are of course with john
what is it like working with these you
know fellow esteemed actors
well with john it's very intimidating
because
um you know i don't work often i get
very rusty
and i just walked up to him right away
and i said
make me good in this just whatever it
takes kick me
smack me whatever
yeah don't let me get away with anything
and uh
he laughed and he was always so
complimentary so you just
you walk out of the off the set every
day kind of puffed up and feeling good
i have to tell you a line in the movie
that
totally just like melted my heart into a
million pieces
no it feels like spaghetti in your gut
you know your your fans of you of john
corbett
people just love the two of you together
as a couple what is it about him that
makes you feel
like you've got a little spaghetti in
your gut
um you know it's that twinkle in his
eye his humor um
his he has a lot of joy in him
and i feed off of it
i just love it and the simplest things
can make him so happy and
so he makes my day brighter because of
that too
and he's got a wicked sense of humor
what has
quarantined life on the ranch with you
too like what has that looked like
and how has it been well obviously a lot
has changed we're both here for an
extended period of time normally we're
ships
passing in the night and here's three
weeks and here's a month and then
one of us has to leave but this has been
the most time we've ever spent together
but living um out in the country you
know you wake up you have your coffee
you feed the horses you feed the dogs
you feed yourself
and you start this routine so that part
of it
has kept us busy occupied and it's my
favorite part
i work so that i can live here and then
um but i could tell at the beginning i
know i did it and i
i think i saw it in in john 2 a
conscious
effort to get along and maybe
if there was something that wasn't going
your way not standing up for yourself
this time
let it go um we don't
and it's been really good for us to
learn these lessons
don't forget also if you're kind of
famous you know you go out and you work
and people kiss your rear end all the
time and then you come home
and your partner goes uh-uh that's not
gonna work anymore
you know i think i think we both have
some of that
when we when we first get home i love
that that's
absolutely a couple keeping it real with
each other nearly
20 years of seemingly very
happily unmarried years between the two
of you do you think living on the ranch
away from los angeles has been somewhat
of a contributing factor to
being as you know blissfully in love as
you as you are
well i know that i it was a big gesture
for
john to move up here because he was
definitely a
nighttime guy and
a city guy and when he first came up to
visit me i remember him saying about
four o'clock what do you people do all
day
and at night you know eight o'clock well
don't you know how to have
fun it's so early kind of comments
and then slowly he just started spending
more time and more time
up here and now it takes a lot to get
them to leave how many pairs of shoes
does one person need
that is not the way to get out of this
alive i re-binged
sex in the city during quarantine you
have
oh of course so i have to ask you the
inevitable
are you a sex in the city fan and where
does your loyalty lie
team big or team aiden
yes i'm a fan i was a fan before i met
john
um which one was i i was
i i can't i don't know if i think i was
big
uh for her not for me for her
okay what what did you not like about
aiden
i just didn't think he was right for her
i think he was right for a lot of women
um but for her i didn't think so i think
she made the right choice
do you ever think about what like a pop
culture moment that was do you guys ever
talk about that
i don't know that we've ever talked
about it but um
yeah it comes up it's really interesting
so well written
really worthy of binging again it's so
creative i
loved it i loved both movies also
and i miss the girls don't you miss them
i'd like to know what they're going
through now i just got to circle back to
20 years together what is the secret
i mean you have to be in love um
really deeply in love were such
opposites in so many ways
when we started out that we took this
relationship one day at a time
and it just happens to be
19 years later we're still together and
we're gonna go for one more day
you know after 20 years a lot of people
wonder
you know are they gonna tie the knot
what is your answer to that and how do
you feel when you get asked that
question
i don't mind being asked because it's
we're the we're the abnormal people and
it
um it's not really a conscious decision
not to it just doesn't
at our age we're not going to have
children uh we're not
building a new family together that this
is important to
a family tree and uh so it it
for us it would just be a piece of paper
a formality yeah
it's been almost 41 years
since the movie 10 graced our screens
and made us fall in love with you bo um
what do you remember about that
experience
it well obviously it was life changing
for me i wasn't an aspiring actress so i
was
so unprepared for becoming
famous overnight and having you know
being followed by paparazzi every place
i went and
having um you know things
written about you that not just
aren't true they got very personal and
uh
and pretty nasty but at the same time
when you're in a
in a successful movie it's like this
magic global credit card
you can do almost anything you want to
do you can meet
almost anyone you want to meet and if
you
keep rem i kept reminding myself okay
this is a pain
definitely but look what i'm getting out
of it the positive obviously
still a massive moment in pop culture
today
you in your swimsuit with your braids
running down the beach
did you know in that moment when you
were filming that scene
that you would instantaneously be turned
into
a global phenomenon no
and if you if you were to to read the
script i'm hardly in the movie
so i thought i was very lucky i was
getting a great trip to mexico
and that's about all i expected of the
movie and the braids
um you know that's become kind of
controversial now
my mom worked for a margaret um and was
her hairdresser in vegas
so backup singer had these
beautiful braids in her hair and so i
tried it i thought it was really pretty
and blake liked it for the movie and i
wore them in the movie
now i get criticized as being you know
i forget the terms they change every day
but culture vultures
stands out but i can tell you at the
time i
when i wore them every place i went
african-american women came up to me and
said thank you
you've made this mainstream you've made
it acceptable
um i can wear braids to my work now at
the bank or wherever i want
so it's hard to imagine that a boss
would come up to a woman now and say you
can't wear your hair that way
but only a short time ago they did so
that's that was my experience with the
braids i was just copying
and i wouldn't do it now because i think
now it would be it is hurtful to some
people
i did bow derek braids
and i'm really into it when you see
someone like kim kardashian
braid her hair and she could bo derek
braids
what was your reaction to that she got a
lot of trouble for calling them the bow
braids
i just think i think people are very
sensitive right now
for 40 years it hasn't been a problem
and i
still get tagged on social media all the
time
um hairdressers who specialize in this
braid
in these braids for african-american
women i still get tagged all the time oh
i did the bo derek today and
and they tagged me and uh so but i think
it's just
we're very sensitive right now and i
wouldn't want to do anything
to to hurt anyone's feelings i think
she's beautiful
and i understand what she was trying to
do
i mean we all
have moments where we'll try to put on
the
hat that someone else wore that we
admire in the age of reboots bo
could you see or would you want to see
10
rebooted today i hope so i really hope
so it's a it's a great story
it there i've heard some really fun
ideas
to bring it and make it contemporary i
know rob schneider was working on it for
a while
and he would have been fantastic would
you make a cameo or an appearance a
little wink wink to the camera
of course okay of course in a second and
at one point i was going to be the
girl's mother
and then now i would have to be her
grandmother i want to congratulate you
on your documentary that recently came
out i think it's kind of
like kind of like a lifetime achievement
award it means that you've had this
fully multifaceted incredible life
with so many dynamic moments in it um
what did that mean to you
i i thought everyone knew everything
about me
but i was reminded by the producer that
that was a long time ago
but the linda evans part
really knocked me down for people who
don't
know she was married to my husband john
derek
when we got together and it was very
difficult and it was a very
emotional and and in many ways sad time
and i've never heard linda talk about it
she
never did she was always so private and
she's this incredibly
fantastic woman and so it was really it
was interesting that she decided to do
it
what did linda's participation mean to
you
completely caught me by surprise
repetition
her participation and then to see her
open up
so much and be so honest in it
it made me cry i think when she
explained
how painful it was for her the breakup
and the fact that i was part of that um
i'd never heard her side of the story
and
i'll never forgive myself for being part
of that
um the breakup of that marriage
that doesn't mean i think about it every
day but i know i learned from it and i
would never
do it again and never have how do you
get
to a place where things were so
contentious
and then you fast forward a couple
decades and now you and linda are
friends how do you get to that place
she made she made the move in the very
beginning to remain friends
with john and with me
and so i've always felt very blessed
that that she reached out and continued
our friendship
um it was an it it's a
takes a very strong woman to do that i
think
you sit here before me today and you
just seem so
happy at the place in life that you're
at do you see yourself
being in acting projects for the
foreseeable future or do you see
yourself maybe taking a step back
to focus on you know other things that
are important to you
i have the best of both worlds now i um
i can go off and work and do fun
projects like this this john boyt movie
and you know go to work with james khan
i have the best of both worlds right now
[Music]